well anyway David you're here because we
have a question that may be of interest
to you hi Mike and Jesse what's the
story behind the remote Conan trains his
successor how did David hopping get
picked for this segment and more
importantly which writer was responsible
for it anyway I love the podcast Lourdes
do you remember doing that remote okay
it's all gone you were the writer for
that right yeah yeah I'm happy ending
but I'm glad that you're here because I
don't remember a lot I don't remember
how I got picked I remember you telling
me I was picked but I don't know how I
got picked well to be honest I think I
pitched it more broadly than that I
pitch it just as Conan training a
successor okay
um like he was going to leave the Empire
to somebody and needed to have a needed
to have somebody that so you picked
gonna take off your idea yeah there's no
idea that's great but I don't I didn't
say specifically who the person would be
and somehow in the writer's room we
talked in your you you became the guy
wow yeah
um and I don't know if it was just like
we knew you were good already being on
camera and that you and Conan had kind
of a funny Rapport and you know what
this speaks very well of you David
because if the writers together in a
room are like zeroed in on you that
means
I think don't you agree like in
everyone's exposure to David they're
like oh you know what he's a cool guy
he'd be good on camera for sure yeah
because we knew that you weren't gonna
get too hammy that you were going to
kind of right be able to be yourself oh
that's nice yeah and and I think we just
thought it was a funny
um I don't know that like because you're
so game for everything you just have to
like say yes uh-huh yeah and so we knew
Conan would enjoy telling you what to do
yeah and that you would probably say yes
the whole thing was just to repeat after
Conan yeah yeah we're gonna go in and
talk to the writers now they're meeting
okay the way I usually do it is I kick
open the door okay I make a lot of kind
of silly over-the-top jokes about how
horrible the writing's been lately even
when it's been good okay okay
[Applause]
this High I was in a barnyard last time
I saw a piled up this side I was in
a barnyard
I always leave the room on a huge laugh
so take care of that
[Music]
so long on you pieces of
[Applause]
and you're very All-American I mean
you're familiar right yeah the
Carbondale area Carlinville goddammit oh
isn't it near just tell me it's like
three hours away I think maybe
it's so close to each other well anyway
I know nothing about you well and
another writer worked on this too Levi
McDougall yes and I I just vaguely
remember us filming that day uh we had
to put you in a Conan wig the wig so
that was kind of you had to go into like
extensive hair and makeup that's how
extensive
no I remember going down and they just
like yeah put like some glue and then
just
and can I ask you guys what was Conan
while you were shooting it was Conan
like
was part of him like oh someone to
replace me eh or
I think I was so nervous the whole time
that there was no threat
you didn't seem nervous at all that's
nice of you to say no but seriously
that's I love hearing that well one
thing I didn't remember but when I was
going back through old emails there was
actually so the first segment went well
we basically got you dressed up and you
did some monologue jokes and learned the
string dance yes
um did you learn the nipple touch no no
okay that's that's true yes too advanced
but we were supposed to do a second
installment of this oh yeah where you
were learning how to interview a
celebrity and we had reached out and I
know uh Paula Davis our Booker had
reached out to Mayim Bialik oh yeah and
so you and Conan were going to interview
her together I forgot about that I know
and then it never ended up happening one
of the travel shows came up oh maybe
that's what it was like
oh that's a shame it's just one of those
things that never never got to just go
back on TBS real quick we'll just do it
again yeah well we'll we'll keep that in
a can if we ever come back that's the
first thing we have a surprise for you
here's my feelings
so one thing that I can't believe when I
look back on this is you weren't even
Conan's assistant at that time you were
you were a PA on the show yeah what what
was your title I was personal PA for
Conan and Jeff so I reported a Sona okay
so you're sona's assistant yeah
um and so how much interaction had you
actually had with Conan I had had quite
a bit like from day one I remember Sona
brought me in and wanted me to get to
know Conan like right off the bat
because I mean I was immediately like
you know running his personal errands
and stuff like yeah cleaning his
underwear exactly that's a normal thing
so you go to college
[Laughter]
you already kind of had a stick with
code is he already making fun of you for
things oh yeah right away yeah
what was his um I mean what was he
getting you for like what was this what
was his thing with you being from a
small town I think is the oh yeah the
Midwest was like the number one okay
that is still stuck around yeah oh well
one once it's locked it's never leaving
it's never leaving oh my gosh this is
just making me remember did was there
something in like your hometown paper
about this front page yeah oh my God
yeah I still have it framed in my
apartment oh that's fantastic well after
this remote aired that that ran in your
paper yeah they reached out and like did
like an interview with me they reached
out you didn't call them guys do I have
a scoop for you
Hometown boy makes good
so they reached out they reached out
they did like an interview Conan and I
took a picture and sent it to him and
yeah wow so people back home you you you
won a sentence
have you gone back for a high school
reunion no they did a five-year reunion
but I missed it because I was here yeah
it got canceled because of covid so all
right 15 will be my time okay well
you're gonna go back don't feel you need
to go to any High School reunions but if
you you know if you've been Conan
successor either way that you know
either way it's you're gonna be like no
one will give you the satisfaction
okay well we disagree I want to hear
about what happened at your high school
I don't want to talk about okay
whatever you assume it oh it was fine
[Laughter]
I mean in a weird way though you do I
mean because now you are Conan's
assistant and you know what he does
almost better than anybody else in a way
you really are most equipped to become
his successor I guess so you know where
all his wills are probably I know I mean
once I got the banking info I knew I
knew I was in oh my God
that's how did we get in we'll talk
later okay well I talk later so his
credit card number is yes
we also need the expiration and the
security of course the billing zip code
of yeah The Villages of code yes